[Musique]
m
la première fois qu'on fait vraiment un
véhicule qui volent mais qui zéro
émission au niveau par action donc ça
veut dire le véhicule et les baser sur
des patries on travaille avec la
nouvelle génération à des batteries pour
faire en sorte que pendant toute la
partie du vol il n'y a pas deux
émissions à haut niveau ces eaux
[Musique]
et c'est un moyen de transport pour
l'individu avec la possibilité vraiment
de faire quelque chose connecter deux
points qu'on ne peut pas connecté
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ces nouvelles technologies comme le
premier portable comme la première
voiture que au début ça va être
certainement un marché de niche mais
notre ambition est très claire de
vouloir démocratiser ça
[Musique]